I wasn't always very excited about math
I was more excited about reading novels
and I thought I would become a writer
one day I got excited about it maybe
just as a challenge but then I realized
that it's really nice and that I enjoy
it
these were quite difficult times it was
during the war right after the world had
a lot of opportunities I went to a very
good middle school and then high school
and I think I got the lucky generation
because I was a teenager and things
became more stable my main interest is
understanding structures you can put on
a surface there are different ways of
looking at it either you have a surface
with some additional geometric
structures or those kind of problems are
related to understanding the space of
such structures one very famous example
is if you have a billiard table and you
start from a point and you hit the ball
and then hits the boundaries and it
moves say forever you want to see the
trajectory of the ball would it cover
all your billiard table can you find
closed billiard paths and interestingly
enough this is an open question in
general if you don't put any switches on
the angles of the polygon that you
started there are two types of questions
one is about you have a surface with a
geometric structure and you're trying to
understand some properties of this
geometric structure that you have the
other questions are related to you have
a surface and you have a geometric
structure and you start the forming as
to your metrics structure and then you
want to see what kind of surfaces you
would get some of the problem is like
you know the properties of a generic
surface a random surface but it's really
hard to say something about a single
given geometric structure on the surface
some of the work that I've done with
different collaborators shows that
sometimes the surfaces are very similar
to the ones of generic surface you can
ask these questions about hyperbolic
surfaces or these flat surfaces or
different geometric structures I think
these problems are important because
they are related to some other problems
even if you are interested in higher
dimensional manifolds one way of dealing
with that is trying to find some nice
surface inside of them you end up
learning a lot about other spaces and
properties of other actions so it gives
you a lot of information it's not only
the question but the way you try to
solve it